THE FIRST TIME TRUMP'S TEAM HAS
SPOKEN IN A FILING IN THIS
SITUATION.
>> ABSOLUTELY, KATELYN, THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT.
I WANT TO GET OVER TO CNN'S EVAN
PEREZ WITH NEW REPORTING JUST IN
TO CNN WITH REGARD TO THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES AND HUNDREDS
OF DOCUMENTS.
WHAT IS THIS?
>> THIS IS A LETTER THAT WAS
POSTED LAST NIGHT BY JOHN
SOLOMON, A CONSERVATIVE
JOURNALIST ON HIS WEBSITE, AND
IT IS A LETTER FROM MAY FROM THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES TO
REPRESENTATIVES OF FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
AND IT IS AN EXTRAORDINARY
LETTER BECAUSE IT DESCRIBES FOR
THE FIRST TIME NOW PUBLICLY WE
CAN SEE WHAT THEY SAY THEY FOUND
WHEN THEY RETRIEVED THE 15 BOXES
OF DOCUMENTS IN JANUARY FROM
MAR-A-LAGO.
700 PAGES CONTAINED, 100 PAGES
WITH CLASSIFIED INFORMATION, AND
INCLUDING INFORMATION UNDER THIS
VERY, VERY SENSITIVE CATEGORY,
THE SPECIAL ACCESS PROGRAMS.
THIS IS STUFF THAT EVEN IF YOU
HAVE THE TOP SECURITY CLEARANCE,
YOU NEED ADDITIONAL CLEARANCE TO
BE ABLE TO ACCESS THESE TYPES OF
INFORMATION.
WHAT THE LETTER REALLY
DESCRIBES, KATE, FOR THE FIRST
TIME, WE KNOW, YOU KNOW, THE
BACK AND FORTH THAT WAS
HAPPENING BETWEEN THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES, BETWEEN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, AND THE FBI, AND THE
FBI WANTING TO GO IN THERE, AND
LOOK AT THESE DOCUMENTS TO DO AN
ASSESSMENT OF THE SECURITY
DAMAGE FROM HAVING THESE
DOCUMENTS STORED IN AN UNSECURED
LOCATION AT THE PRESIDENT -- THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S BEACH HOUSE,
AND YOU SEE THERE, GIVING GREAT
DEFERENCE TO FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP OVER A PERIOD OF WEEKS,
KATE.
>> THIS IS IMPORTANT.
JUST THAT SHEER SCALE AND NUMBER
OF THE NUMBER OF DOCUMENTS
DEEMED CLASSIFIED, THAT'S REALLY
QUITE SOMETHING.
EVAN, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THAT.
I APPRECIATE IT.
JOINING ME RIGHT NOW FOR MORE ON
THIS IS FORMER TRUMP WHITE HOUSE
ACTING CHIEF OF STAFF MICK
MULVANEY.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
YOU HEARD THE REPORTING JUST IN
FROM EVAN AS I JUST DID, 15
BOXES THAT WE KNOW WERE
RETRIEVED FROM MAR-A-LAGO IN
JANUARY.
700 PAGES, MORE THAN 100
DOCUMENTS DEEMED CLASSIFIED.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT
NUMBER?
>> WELL, THE NUMBER IS CERTAINLY
LARGE, THE CLASSIFIED IS AN
IMPORTANT PART THERE, KATE, BY
THE WAY, THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME.
CLASSIFIED COVERS A WHOLE RANGE
OF THINGS, THIS COULD BE LOW
CLASSIFICATIONS, MEDIUM
COLLABORATIONS, STUFF THAT IS
TSSCI, TOP SECRET, ET CETERA.
THAT CATCHES MY ATTENTION,
INCLUDING THE STUFF THAT IS
DESIGNATED AS SAP, SPECIAL ACT
ACCESS PROGRAMS.
THE SAP MATERIALS IS STUFF THAT
YOU ARE SUPPOSED TO SIGN IN FOR,
SIGN OUT FOR, GO TO A SPECIAL
PLACE TO READ, IT WOULD BE VERY,
VERY DIFFICULT TO ACCIDENTALLY
WALK OFF WITH THOSE DOCUMENTS.
SO I WOULD BE CURIOUS IF WE
LEARN ANY MORE.
WE PROBABLY WILL NOT SEE WHAT
THOSE DOCUMENTS ARE, BECAUSE
THEY'RE SO SENSITIVE.
BUT ANY INFORMATION MIGHT SHED
IN SLIGHT ON HOW THEY ENDED UP
IN MAR-A-LAGO.
>> THAT'S WHAT I WAS GOING TO
ASK YOU, FROM YOUR EXPERIENCE,
IN CONGRESS, AND YOUR EXPERIENCE
IN THE WHITE HOUSE, HOW EASY
WOULD IT BE OR REASONABLE WOULD
IT BE FOR SOMEONE TO BELIEVE
THESE DOCUMENTS WOULD BE TAKEN
OFF ACCIDENTALLY, ESPECIALLY
THESE VERY TOP CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS?
>> THAT'S TWO DIFFERENT
QUESTIONS.
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION, YEAH,
YOU CAN EASILY THROW A BUNCH OF
STUFF IN A BOX OF DOCUMENTS AND
THERE MIGHT BE CLASSIFIED
MATERIALS IN THERE.
CLASSIFICATION COVERS A LARGE
BROAD SORT OF VARIETY OF
DOCUMENTS.
TSSCI AND SAP IS DIFFERENT.
THOSE ARE DOCUMENTS WITH SPECIAL
COVERS.
WITH THE SAP MATERIALS, YOU HAVE
TO SIGN UP AND SIGN OUT FOR
THEM.
IT MAKES ME WONDER WHAT HAPPENED
TO THE CHAIN OF CUSTODY OF THE
DOCUMENTS.
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE SOMEBODY,
TYPICALLY AT THE NATIONAL
SECURITY, THAT IS JOHN BOLTON'S
OFFICE, OR ROBERT O'BRIEN'S
OFFICE, THAT'S SUPPOSED TO TRACK
THOSE DOCUMENTS.
SO THE LARGE NUMBER OF DOCUMENTS
DOESN'T NECESSARILY GET MY
ATTENTION.
AGAIN, IT IS THE SMALL NUMBER OF
TSSCI AND SPECIAL ACCESS
DOCUMENTS THAT HAS ME SCRATCHING
MY HEAD.
>> YEAH.
ALSO I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT
THIS LAWSUIT THAT TRUMP'S TEAM
FILED ASKING FOR A SPECIAL
MASTER TO REVIEW THE DOCUMENTS
THAT WERE TAKEN IN THE FBI
SEARCH OF MAR-A-LAGO.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THIS
REQUEST?
>> IT DOESN'T SURPRISE ME.
IT TELEGRAPHS THE TRUMP TEAM
DOESN'T TRUST THE FBI.
KEEP IN MIND, IF YOU PUT YOUR
TRUMP HAT ON AND LOOK AT THIS
THROUGH HIS PERSPECTIVE THIS IS
THE SAME FBI THAT PRESENTED
FALSE INFORMATION ABOUT HIM TO A
JUDGE AS PART OF A FISA COURT
INVESTIGATION INTO THE -- OR
SURVEILLANCE OF THE 2016 TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
THERE IS SOME VERY BAD BLOOD
BETWEEN THE FBI AND PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
SO FOR THEM TO SAY, LOOK, WE
DON'T WANT THE FILTER TEAM,
WHICH IS AN INTERNAL TEAM TO THE
FBI GOING THROUGH THESE
DOCUMENTS, WE WANT AN
INDEPENDENT THIRD PARTY MASTER.
WHY?
BECAUSE SOME OF THESE DOCUMENTS,
YES, THEY COULD BE SPECIAL
BECAUSE HE'S PRESIDENT.
THAT'S STUFF WE COVER BY
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
THERE MAY BE MATERIALS, AND I
BELIEVE THEY'RE CONTENDING THERE
ARE, THAT WOULD BE
ATTORNEY/CLIENT PRIVILEGE THAT
EVERYBODY WOULD BE ENTITLED TO.
SO, YEAH, THERE IS A LOW LEVEL
OF TRUST BETWEEN THE FBI AND THE
TRUMPS.
THE MOTION FOR THE SPECIAL
MASTER DOES NOT SURPRISE ME.
AND MY GUT IS THAT IT IS
PROBABLY ONE OF THE THINGS COURT
WILL BE ABLE TO AWARD TRUMP IN
THE FILING OF THIS ARGUMENT.
>> THE MESSAGE, THE FULL BREADTH
OF THE MESSAGE THAT TRUMP SAYS
HE SENT TO ATTORNEY GENERAL
MERRICK GARLAND, THEY LAY IT OUT
IN THE FILING.
LET ME READ THIS.
THIS IS THE MESSAGE THEY SAID
WAS DELIVERED TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WANTS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO KNOW THAT HE
HAS BEEN HEARING FROM PEOPLE ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY ABOUT THE RAID.
IF THERE WAS ONE WORD TO
DESCRIBE THEIR MOOD, IT IS
ANGRY.
THE HEAT IS BUILDING UP, THE
PRESSURE IS BUILDING UP,
WHATEVER I CAN DO TO TAKE THE
HEAT DOWN, TO BRING THE PRESSURE
DOWN, JUST LET US KNOW.
WHAT DO YOU THINK DONALD TRUMP
WAS TRYING TO SAY HERE?
DO YOU SEE THAT MESSAGE AS
THREATENING?
>> YEAH, WELL, MY GUESS IS THAT
HOW YOU INTERPRET THAT MESSAGE
PROBABLY DEPENDS IN LARGE PART
ABOUT HOW YOU PERCEIVE FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE HIM, YOU SEE A
VEILED THREAT.
IF YOU LIKE HIM, YOU TAKE THE
DOCUMENT ON ITS FACE VALUE.
I SEND A TEXT TO MARK MEADOWS
THAT SAID LET ME KNOW IF I CAN
HELP AND MY INTENT WAS TO SAY,
LET ME KNOW IF I CAN HELP, NO
THREATENING MESSAGE.
I TAKE THE MESSAGE AT FACE
VALUE.
YOU PROBABLY SHOULD UNTIL YOU
GET MORE DETAIL AROUND IT.
IT WOULDN'T SURPRISE ME THAT
FOLKS WHO DON'T LIKE DONALD
TRUMP SEE A VEILED THREAT IN
THAT.
>> THE FILING TALKS ABOUT THE
STORAGE ROOM IN MAR-A-LAGO WHERE
THESE DOCUMENTS WERE KEPT.
DURING YOUR TIME AS CHIEF, DID
YOU KNOW ABOUT A STORAGE ROOM, A
STORAGE UNIT IN MAR-A-LAGO WHERE
DOCUMENTS MAY HAVE BEEN KEPT?
>> WELL, WE DIDN'T STORE
DOCUMENTS THERE.
AT LEAST NOT A LOT OF THEM.
WE BRING DOCUMENTS WITH US WHEN
WE GO DOWN ON THE WEEKENDS AND
SO FORTH.
THERE WAS A BASEMENT I WAS
FAMILIAR WITH, THE UNITED STATES
SECRET SERVICE USED, I'M NOT
SURE IF THAT'S THE SAME PLACE.
WHAT JUMPS OUT IN MY MIND ABOUT
THE STORAGE OF THE DOCUMENTS AT
MAR-A-LAGO WAS THAT THE FBI WAS
THERE, IN JANUARY, I BELIEVE,
TOOK THE FIRST 15 DOCUMENTS THAT
YOU MENMENTIONED EARLIER, BACK
JUNE AND RECOMMEND ADDITIONAL
SECURITY BE PLACED.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL ME?
YOU CAN READ THAT AS SAYING
WELL, THERE WAS NOT ENOUGH
SECURITY, PROBABLY AN ARGUABLE
POINT.
BUT ALSO THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION -- THE TRUMP TEAM
SEEMS TO HAVE DONE THAT.
SO IF THE FBI WAS THERE, IN
JANUARY, AND WENT BACK IN JUNE,
AND THEN SENT A NOTE ABOUT
INCREASING THE SECURITY, MAKES
ME WONDER WHY THEY DIDN'T DO
MORE AT THAT PARTICULAR TIME.
SO I DON'T FOCUS MUCH ON THE
BUILDING.
WHEN WE WERE THERE, IT WAS
DIFFERENT.
HE WAS THE SITTING PRESIDENT,
THE SECURITY WAS OUTRAGEOUSLY
TIGHT, AT LEAST TO GET ON THE
PROPERTY.
ONCE ON THE PROPERTY, YOU COULD
MOVE AROUND A LITTLE BIT, AND MY
GUESS IT IS A MUCH LOWER LEVEL
OF SECURITY NOW, BUT THE FBI
KNOWS A LOT MORE ABOUT THE
SECURITY AT THE BUILDING RIGHT
NOW THAT I'M GOING TO, SO I'M
NOT SURE WHAT THE ISSUE IS ON
THE SECURITY AT THE BUILDING
ITSELF.
>> LET ME ALSO ASK YOU, IN THIS
FILING, THEY MAKE IT VERY CLEAR,
THEY SAY THEY BELIEVE THAT
DONALD TRUMP IS NOT ONLY THE
FRONT-RUNNER TO -- IN THE 2024
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY,
BUT ALSO THE FRONT-RUNNER IN THE
2024 GENERAL ELECTION SHOULD HE
DECIDE TO RUN.
HE SEES HIMSELF AS A
FRONT-RUNNER IN 2024.
DO YOU WANT TO SEE HIM RUN?
>> SURE, MY GUESS ANYBODY
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT PERCEIVED
THEMSELVES AS BEING A
FRONT-RUNNER.
LIZ CHENEY SEES IT HERE IN THE
LAST COUPLE OF DAYS.
I'VE BEEN VERY PUBLIC.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT'S POLICIES
SPOKE TO ME AS A CONSERVATIVES
AND REPUBLICAN, I WAS VERY
PLEASED WITH THE POLICIES WE PUT
IN PLACE IN THE ADMINISTRATION.
I THINK WE'RE AT THE POINT WHERE
DONALD TRUMP MAY BE THE ONLY
REPUBLICAN IF THE ELECTION WERE
HELD TODAY WHO MIGHT LOSE TO JOE
BIDEN.
THE ENVIRONMENT IS VERY
FAVORABLE TO REPUBLICANS AND
THERE IS ANY NUMBER OF THEM WHO
COULD BEAT JOE BIDEN, IN MY
OPINION, FAIRLY EASILY.
DONALD TRUMP WOULD HAVE A
DIFFICULT TIME DOING THAT AND
COULD LOSE TO JOE BIDEN.
AS A REPUBLICAN, I'M THINKING TO
MYSELF, IF I CAN GET THE
POLICIES THAT TRUMP REPRESENTS,
WITHOUT HAVING THE BAGGAGE THAT
TRUMP REPRESENTS, WHY WOULDN'T
WE DO THAT AS A PARTY.
I THINK THERE IS A GROWING
NUMBER OF REPUBLICANS THAT SEE
IT THAT WAY.
>> YOU'RE FACED WITH THE
QUESTION OF, WOULD YOU HAVE
TROUBLE VOTING FOR HIM?
>> I GET THAT QUESTION ALL THE
TIME.
WE VOTE IN SECRET, I DON'T WANT
TO MAKE IT BY MYSELF, BUT THERE
IS A LOT OF REPUBLICANS WHO
LIKED HIM, VOTED FOR HIM TWICE,
HOPE HE DOESN'T RUN AGAIN TO NOT
PUT US IN THAT SITUATION.
THERE IS SOME REALLY, REALLY
GOOD REPUBLICANS OUT THERE.
AND REGARDLESS OF HOW THIS FBI
INVESTIGATION GOES, REGARDLESS
OF HOW THE JANUARY 6th
INVESTIGATION GOES, DONALD TRUMP
STILL EMBODIES A LOT OF ANGER ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE,
THAT A LOT OF THE REPUBLICANS
DON'T.
SO I THINK THERE IS A GROWING
NUMBER OF REPUBLICANS WHO PREFER
TO SEE HIM NOT RUN.
THERE HAS BEEN A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT, KATE, OF SYMPATHY FOR
HIM IN THE LAST TWO WEEKS FROM
ALL SORTS OF POTENTIAL
CHALLENGERS IN 2024, CRITICS
SUCH AS MYSELF WHO HAVE DEFENDED
HIM IN RESPONSE TO THIS RA